hey everyone it's mike from horror flows
and today is August 10th 2018 it's a
quick video I'm shooting on the order
fellas market analysis for this Friday
August 10th and this week you know
earlier this week we just started our
weekly order foes group training session
group live training session with me
it meets Monday nights at 7 p.m. Central
Time and you know it's weekly thing
they'll be recorded and there they're
put in a special archive section in the
members area so you just go in and you
I'm gonna try and create a video to show
you how to get to it you know it's a
it's not a simple thing where says
archive section here you got to go to
manage recordings and stuff like that
but I'm gonna try and teach you how to
get to that so before I jump into the
analysis I want to do today just go
through a brief disclaimer this
presentation is for educational and
informational purposes only should not
be considered a solicitation to buy or
sell a futures contract or making any
other type of investment decision future
strain contains essential risk is not
for every investor investor potentially
was all more than the initial investment
risk couple is money that could be lost
without jeopardizing one's financial
security relax the only risk couple
shoot abuser training only those were
sufficient rich capital should consider
training past importance is not
necessarily indicative of future results
now you know the reason why I put that
there is because you know people
sometimes think that you know trading is
easy and you know it's the the way to
riches
you know it's yeah can you make a good
living trading yes you can you know I
know a lot of people that that's what
they do for a living is they trade
that's how they make their money that's
what I have been doing for the last 20
years I've been involved in the markets
you know as a as a trader and you know
more recently as someone that works with
other traders people always say you know
hey Mikey are you such a good trader you
know you come off as well you know some
you're some market wizard no I don't you
know I come off as somebody who has 20
years experience trading at a very high
level I'm not gonna say the highest
level but you know I spent eight years
at JP Morgan I spent four years at
Cargill 3 years of Commerce Bank you
know a few years at ETF man so you know
you don't live to survive that long in
trading environment unless you know your
you're decent at it and let's say you
know you gotta be great at it but you
know you gotta be decent at it too to to
survive but anyway you know one of the
things that I want to talk about is the
some trade setups you know and I've
always talked about certain trade setups
you know going back years and and one of
them is the ratio and divergence in the
order flow right you know divergence is
the you know new or equal low with
positive Delta or new equal high with
negative Delta but what makes my order
flows divergence is you know I include a
little bit of price action into it you
know because you know just because you
make a new low with positive Delta you
know I want the market to be confirming
it with the price action as well so
rather you know if this funny side note
is you know a buddy of mine who's you
know really into order flow he consumes
everything that comes out on an order
flow and he says he met this guy who had
this quote secret to order flow analysis
secret and you know share it with you
for a couple undred dollars okay so my
buddy send him a couple hundred dollars
and basically all it was was just
divergence you know I say you know you
buy it when you know you get it low and
you got positive Delta you know he's
like whispering it like that like it's
some secret it's not you know I mean
this is something that's been around for
for many years and you know and I'll the
problem that I've always had with with
the normal divergence is you know on a
market that's trending you're gonna get
you know new lows with positive deltas
um you know and I say you gotta add some
price sex price action to it you know
you need some confirmation in the price
action that hey you know we are starting
to move up from that low and you know
that's what my order flows trader
software does is it adds price action
into the normal divergence and the
straight setup that I've always been
talking about four years since I
released my software was the ratio which
is this blue number you know it's a blue
ratio is is in ratio that I like I find
in the order flow being either
supportive or in the indicative of price
rejection so it's either price support
or price rejection depending on how the
number comes out and if it's just the
black number that's just doing your
regular order flow okay and to set up
that I like then I've been
couple years is this one the ratio and
divergence in the bar in the same bar or
divergence and in the following bar a
ratio so what I want to sort of explain
is you need when you trade right you
should have more than one trade set that
you look for and this was a question
that someone emailed me on the other day
is you know how many trade setups do you
have well yeah I've got a handful okay
but really what I'm looking for is you
know my bread and butter which is racial
divergence and and a newer one that you
know is it made a lot easier the primary
point of control and a ratio and you
know it's something that you can see if
you use my order flows trader software
again yah had people say well you're
don't watch this videos because all he
does is talk about his software and you
gotta buy a software well that's one of
the reasons why I create these videos is
for users of my software so they can
look for the same trades right and I
talked about these setups all the time
you know ratio and divergence or ratio
sorry divergence and a ratio in the next
bar so here you know if you're just
trading ratio and divergence this one
fails okay
you would be stopped out period you know
it's no way around it and I'm not gonna
say well you get out here because it
looks like no really stopped out but
then down here if you're trading ratio
and divergence right you got your
divergence interracial in the next bar
and the market you know made of the nice
little rally but you know the other set
up right to get you in just before the
divergence and the ratio and the next
bar is the ratio I'm sorry the
divergence and the prominent point
control divergence and prominent point
control now I've been doing a lot of
videos on this recently
you know webinars over the last couple
months I'm talking about this particular
trade setup and you know why you have to
have more than one trade setup is
because you know if you're just trading
one set up right maybe you get one trade
a day two days two trades a day or
something like that okay well we're
gonna do the rest of the time the
markets trading all right you're gonna
be missing a lot of trading
opportunities that's why you need to
have more than one trade setup and you
know so okay you get this straight here
all right ratio and divergence you
stopped out you took a loss okay ratio
and divergence yeah you got another
trade a few minutes later and
you know it kind of worked out you would
have got something out of it but ratio
and I sorry divergence and a prominent
opponent controls giving you another
trading opportunities right here so you
know everyone likes you know investing
you I see we've got a diversified in
real estate you got diversify you know
even people I got a buddy that sells
sports jerseys on eBay and houses
remember scratching my head and saying
what else is selling says well no you
know that's good you know because these
are autographed jerseys and they sell
for a lot of money well okay well what
happens when people stop buying jerseys
they don't want to buy jerseys you know
it's not like you know there's a big
market for an autographed you know Alex
Rodriguez game-worn Jersey you know
because there's only a certain amount of
fans out there that be interested in it
you know you're yeah you satisfy that
market or you know there may be one guy
looking for that a month or something
like that so you know if people stop you
know if the guy comes out you know I was
juiced up the my entire career you'll
know what's gonna buy you jerseys anyone
even be stuck with all these jerseys and
this is the same thing with training if
you have just one trade set up meanwhile
the rest of the market is training and
you know you don't have anything going
on because you're just sitting there
staring at your screen waiting for the
crates out comments why you need more
than one trades up and and it's
especially true in the sense that you
need you know a lot of times I see
people they have as method of trading
that's deals with range base trades you
know markets that's consolidating well
what you gonna do in the market trending
right you know could be taking a lot of
losses or if you have a trending market
you have a market way of trading the
market when the market is trending we're
gonna do in the market consolidating you
know you gonna be sucking wind so you
need you know different trade setups you
know based on market conditions or you
know just basically you know how many
trades you want to take a day and yeah
so first one it's a loser I mean listed
here along with they're all wait for the
next trade in the next you know the next
trade never comes that day because
you're just looking for one trade set up
that's why you need more than one trade
set up and you know divergence in front
of point control you know and you would
got also the divergence and the ratio on
the next bar as well so at least you
know you're giving yourself a more more
opportunities but where else is there
divergence and a ratio
this day there's that there's no more
you know and even here you get a
divergence and a primary point of
control and another next trade 28 28 all
the way up to 28 38 and I'm not saying
you you know you would've bought a 28
and got out at 38 but you know this is a
nice rally up here I mean there's
nothing going against it telling you to
get out it's all aggressive binds all
imbalances in each bar it's all positive
Delta's you know the first sign of
selling coming in here is is not up to
the 36 area where you start going
sideways in here you know where starts
getting a bit chunky in here and you got
to sell on a balance
so hopefully you could have got you know
at least five full points out of that
move that's what I talk about when I say
you know you got to have more than one
way of approaching the market you know
rather than just saying well I got a
market I got a way of trading the market
you know when it's consolidating because
we consolidate seventy percent of time
we only turn 30 percent of time well
okay well the 30 percent of time you're
taking losses or you know you're not
making any money so you know it's one of
those things you need something that is
you know for different market conditions
you need different ways to approach the
market so my so thanks for watching this
video and if you're interested in the
software go to order flow is calm and
you know I've got a link actually below
this video for a special on the software
if you're interested it's it's a great
little tool to add to your your training
again you know we do these weekly live
group training sessions which are more
in-depth and you know these quick little
videos I shoot for YouTube and it gives
you a chance to interact with me
you know on a live basis and you know
it's only for those that use my software
or you know use the the ninja trader
version or if you have the emoji trading
version you know which comes from Lee
who you know I work with on an order
flow analysis you know he has them for
the sera charts version of order flows
you know just shoot Lee an email and
he'll get you know tell them that hey
you know my saw Mike's video you know I
can get access to it too is uh weekly
training ask Mike to set me up you know
because I get the approval from Lee that
you know you are a user and you know
it's it's it's an informal thing I
your questions to me about order flow or
you know what I think is interesting to
look at in the market or you know why is
something set up a certain way feel free
to join you know I said it's a great
resource for anybody interested in
advancing their knowledge of order flow
you know I mean if you're just someone
that's gonna say well you know order
flow is the secret out I want to learn
it and I'll know everything about the
markets no you know you need to learn
how order flow affects the markets and
and why it happens so thanks everyone
and have a great day and hope to see you
on the live sessions on Monday bye bye